neutral service providers will not
discriminate on the basis of anything
except for conservative politics and
this is why the story that is now coming
out about paypal
and the anti-defamation league is scary
neutral spaces disappear
and that means further polarization and
split in the country
today's story from the authoritarian
front lines this is
an insane story but this is the way the
country is going to go
neutral service providers these are
places that just used to provide you
services this is how you think
of most of the businesses with which you
engage in everyday life your insurance
company is a neutral service provider it
is supposed to provide you service
regardless of race
religion or creed your supermarket a
neutral service provider
and your credit card company is also
supposed to be a neutral service
provider well certainly paypal which is
a payment service right you use paypal
to pay your bills that's supposed to be
a neutral service provider but one of
the things that we have seen
from an increasingly authoritarian left
is the attempt to use
all of these neutral service providers
as bottlenecks
that restrict your ability to speak
freely as ways to crack down
on the undesirables in the opinion
community we've seen this before we've
seen
credit card companies for example say
that you're not allowed to use their
credit cards in order to purchase guns
right this has become a major issue in
the united states you've also seen
places like amazon web services d
platform parlor amazon web services is a
neutral service provider
in the aftermath of january 6th you saw
amazon web services
at the behest of democrats crack down on
parlor and kick it off its platform it
was removed from google it was removed
from
apple store it was removed nearly
everywhere by the tech companies
again all of which were supposed to be
neutral service providers
this is the big debate over big tech big
tech facebook is supposed to be a
neutral service provider it is not
supposed to crack down on you on the
basis
of your ideology now there are folks on
the left who suddenly become free market
libertarians when it comes to the stuff
treating neutral service providers as
though they are basically the daily wire
right they can make whatever call they
want about what content they can and
cannot engage in
and technically that's true these are
not government agencies but when you
have neutral service providers that
overtly decide
they're going to crack down on
particular points of view this is very
bad for the country and we are allowed
to point out that this is very bad
for the country especially because we do
have anti-discrimination law in this
country it applies to race
it applies to religion it now applies to
sexual orientation the one thing it does
not apply to is politics
right neutral service providers
generally are allowed to deny you
service on the basis of your politics
the problem is of course the left has
politicized every single
thing right everything is political so
if you say if you're if you're
a baker you say i don't want to bake
this cake for this same-sex wedding
they'll say
you are doing this not on the basis of
politics you're doing this not on the
basis of world view you're doing this on
the basis of animus
but if a baker says i'm not going to
bake a cake
for your biblical party then the idea is
that's politics
so everything that the left wants to
censor goes in the politics basket
and everything that the left wants to
force you to do goes
in the immutable characteristic basket
that you're not allowed to discriminate
against so the left categories break
down into
the stuff you're not allowed to
discriminate against and the stuff you
are allowed to discriminate against
everything that is remotely conservative
goes in the things you're allowed to
discriminate against basket everything
else goes into things you're not allowed
to discriminate against baskets so when
we talk about neutral service providers
increasingly
neutral service providers will not
discriminate on the basis of anything
except for conservative politics okay
this is why the story that is now coming
out about paypal
and the anti-defamation league is scary
so the anti-defamation league
used to be a much more bipartisan it was
always a left-leaning organization but
sort of a bipartisan organization
largely focused on fighting
anti-semitism that was broadened out to
include discrimination
of all sorts now the anti-defamation
league is basically a democratic front
group unfortunately the anti-defamation
league
in the aftermath of abe foxman's
retirement has basically become
a a sort of talking point organization
for the left
in a similar way to the southern poverty
law center right the basic idea of the
adl
is that you have to focus deeply in any
time there is a republican who does
something anti-semitic this is
worthy of unending scorned and ridicule
fair enough
but if you've got the squad in the
democratic party saying overtly
anti-semitic stuff for years on end this
is stuff that requires maybe a little
bit of
tutting but at that point you sort of
let it go in any case the
anti-defamation league
is now working with paypal a neutral a
neutral service provider in order to
crack down on content
and they say that they're cracking down
on extremist content the problem of
course
is that the left has a really really bad
habit and that habit is conflating
everything they don't like with
extremist content
in the same way that the january 6
commission is largely going to be about
conflating all republican and
conservative ideology with january 6th
and saying that if you supported donald
trump in 2020 it's because you wanted
january 6th to happen
or by the way even if you thought that
the election was decided by fraud
that that makes you a january 6
compatriot okay like i don't agree that
november 4th was decided by fraud i
think that trump lost the election
but there is even a distinction between
the people who went and protested that
day and the people who actually
committed the criminal act of going
onto the capitol grounds breaking in and
threatening people okay but the left
wants to wrap
all of this up involved in the same way
what the what the left would like to do
is broaden out the rubric of extremism
dangerous speech
dangerous incitement to include pretty
much everybody on the right and now
they're going to weaponize neutral
service providers
in order to basically excise you from
the community
of people who get to participate in the
services of a neutral service provider
so according to the anti-defamation
league here is their
here's their press release yesterday and
this is dangerous dangerous stuff
because this is going to be the model
going forward
you've seen this increasingly
advertisers are being told you can
advertise with msnbc you can't advertise
with fox news
you have democrats who are openly
pushing the fcc
to crack down on dissemination of
channels like fox news you saw npr last
week
trying to push facebook 2g platform
daily wire
for no reason other than more
conservative right they said we don't
lie they said that we don't
engage in conspiracy theories they say
that we're openly conservative and we
should be suppressed anyway
the goal here is to take businesses
again which are not subject to first
amendment restrictions because they're
businesses
and through both governmental and social
pressure get them to bottleneck free
speech
that's the goal here so here's the adl's
press release quote paypal holdings in
partnership
with adl today announced a new
partnership initiative to fight
extremism and hate
through the financial industry and
across at-risk communities this is the
latest effort by paypal in combating
racism
hate and extremism across its platforms
and the industry
through this collaboration paypal and
adl have launched a research effort to
address the urgent need
to understand how extremism and hate
movements throughout the united states
are attempting to leverage financial
platforms to fund criminal activity
okay so if we're talking about how
paypal should not be engaged in criminal
activity
or should be restricting its ability to
restricting the ability of people to
use their platform to engage in criminal
activity fine we have those sorts of
regulations with regard to
all sorts of financial transactions we
have those regulations put in place
many of them directly after 9 11 this is
why if you're transferring over 10 000
for example you need to have basically a
delay and the federal government checks
into it and all of that
okay but that's not the entirety of what
paypal and the and the adl are doing
according to aaron karsmer the chief
risk officer and evp
of risk and platforms and paypal quote
by identifying partners across sectors
with common goals and complementary
resources we can make an even greater
impact than any of us could do on our
own
we're excited to partner with the adl
other nonprofits and law enforcement
in our fight against hate in all of its
forms so first of all i am
very uneasy with the with the rubric of
quote hate in all of its forms
because as we have seen many on the left
perceive anything on the right to be
hateful that they disagree with
and if you believe for example that men
are men and women are women this means
that you're a hate monger
according to the left and you should be
suppressed so i have some real
difficulty
in the language here if they want to say
we're cracking down on criminality
that's not even worthy of a press
release
right that's what you should be doing
businesses should of course always be
fighting criminality and illegality but
that's not what we're talking about here
as becomes pretty clear as this press
release goes on
the initiative with paypal will be led
through adl's center on extremism a
leading authority on extremism terrorism
and hate paypal and adl will focus on
uncovering
and disrupting the financial pipelines
that support extremist and hate
movements
in addition to extremist and
anti-government organizations the
initiative will focus here we go
the initiative will focus on actors and
networks spreading
and profiting from all forms of hate and
bigotry
against any community now we're getting
kind of broad aren't we
we went from people engaging in criminal
activity or people associated with
criminal organizations to
focusing on quote actors and networks
spreading and profiting from all forms
of hate
and bigotry against any community now
again this makes me very uneasy because
i do not think that the left is a
particularly circumspect in how they
approach questions of hate and bigotry
as we have seen the president of the
united states this dollaring old
quote-unquote moderate
has spent the last several months
declaring that if you're in favor of
voter id it's because you're akin to a
jim crow racist
so no i don't think that the adl has any
monopoly
on defining hate and bigotry i think the
left has a
horrific habit of declaring everyone
they dislike a hateful bigot
and i i don't think they have any
restrictive principles here at all so
you put that on top of paypal
and now paypal says okay well you want
to subscribe to daily wire or you want
to subscribe to
daily caller or you want to subscribe to
fox nation well you know what they've
been doing over there
tucker carlson white supremacist ben
shapiro hate monger
well i guess we can't use your your
platform anymore in order to pay like
you can see where this is going
and it is nowhere good again if you are
attempting to crack down on criminal
activity i got no problem at all
the nice thing about criminal activity
is to bright line because criminal
activity
has statutorily defined terms that is
not the case with hate
and bigotry it's why we don't prosecute
hate and bigotry in the united states
the way they attempt to
in europe or canada which is a very good
thing we should not prosecute hate and
bigotry in the united states because it
is a fungible term
it is an empty vessel that you can fill
with anyone you don't like jonathan
greenblatt the ceo of the adl says quote
all of us including in the private
sector have a critical role to play in
fighting the spread of extremism and
hate
with this new initiative we're setting a
new standard for companies to bring
their expertise to critical social
issues
we have a unique opportunity to further
understand how hate spreads
and develop key insights that will
inform the efforts of the financial
industry
law enforcement and our communities in
mitigating extremist threats
according to the press release paypal
and adl will work closely with
organizations like the united latin
american centers to protect marginalized
communities
against extremism they will work closely
with them to share trends
and hate with marginalized and
vulnerable communities and with the goal
of helping to empower and safeguard
those communities which are frequently
targets of hate groups
and extremist acts so you can see how
this is going to bleed from
here's a group that participates in
criminal activity we should crack down
on that too
here are the kinds of people that
members of this group might like to
watch
and let's stop them and you can no
longer patronize those sites
the militarization of neutral service
providers in order to avoid the
structures of the first amendment
is a deep and abiding problem in
american life there are only two
possible remedies
one is actual regulation that adds
discrimination on the basis of politics
to anti-discrimination law which i think
the way a lot of
states are going to go now that we've
created a whole rubric of
anti-discrimination law
much of which is in violation of basic
first amendment principles by the way
right you can be against discrimination
and also recognize that
anti-discrimination law
really really impedes on freedom of
association as well as freedom of speech
and both things can be true at once and
racism is terrible and also in the
united states
you do have a right to say racist things
both of those things can be true at once
in the same way
that in the united states i think
pornography is terrible
and still the supreme court has declared
that you have the right to buy
pornography if you're an adult
right just because there is a quote
unquote
right to do something does not mean that
you always approve of the use of the
right
however if we are going to have an
anti-discrimination rubric in the united
states
and we are going to say it's not okay to
discriminate against people on the basis
of everything
from identifying as a member of the
opposite sex to race like that entire
broad spectrum
then the notion the only people who can
be discriminated against are white
conservatives
seems to be a bit of a problem you're
gonna see states fight back against that
that's one possibility the other is
we're just gonna get two separate sets
of
service providers one for conservatives
and one for liberals and listen
we here on the right i'm happy to make
money off of that you know because if
there if there's going to be a right
wing paypal i'm happy to found it
and i'm happy to have people use it it's
fine with me i'll make a lot of money
it is horrible for the country as
neutral spaces disappear
we have no relationship with the people
who live next door to us and that means
this the further polarization and split
in the country all of which i talk about
in the new book the authoritarian moment
but
it is a deep problem it's getting worse
every single day the battle for the
culture is heating up we here at the
daily wear are making some big moves so
be sure to like
subscribe ring that bell because you're
not going to want to miss a single
moment